[Music]
possession this is a horror film that
you have made do you like horror movies
by them oh yeah I love horror movies
enemy growing up it was you know the
omen and The Exorcist and poltergeist I
mean I love those movies yeah yeah and
we we have a clip here from the
possession tell us a little bit about
the movie this is based on a true story
yes it actually is based on a true story
okay so it's called the Dybbuk box and a
dybbuk is a dislocated spirit I don't
know if you know that but a dislocated
spine just look you did not know that I
dislocated evil spirit okay is kept in a
box a bit much somehow they got the
Dybbuk they got the spirit into the box
this these parents are getting a divorce
and the the husband takes this the
little girl on you know his custody time
to a flea market and she buys this box
and then she becomes you know possessed
by this demon very and and we have a
clip here and I believe that's all we
need to know for this clip really I
think so yes all right let's take a look
this clip from the possession
[Music]
[Music]
my Emily
where are you
okay yeah
[Music]
that's exactly how my six-year-old that
I'm watching this and thinking I don't
see the difference between it stabs me
at least twice a day